foreign
Chicago what's up Beth
hello how are you partying how are you
good awesome what's up
thanks for taking my call
um my question is how to let go of the
anger with my father and I'll give you a
little back story
we haven't had a relationship in decades
like he was invited to my wedding didn't
show up
um invited meet his first granddaughter
when she was born didn't come and so
after that I mean I wrote a letter to
him didn't send it but just to get all
my emotions out
and felt like I really had peace about
it because I didn't understand how he
couldn't be there for me and my siblings
even his brother and his mother but
after I had a child it really changed my
perspective on all all of it and I
thought I really do you have mental
illness
you know my siblings and I think we have
diagnosed him you know just in our heads
but we don't know
I would be willing to bet
um a lot that he was struggling with
something pretty profound
yes the act of walking away from your
kids and your grandkids is so unnatural
yes
and I hate that you experience that
thank you
but you know that's not your fault right
no
and I I'd always sit or I said in the
letter that I wrote to him and said you
know the only way I can have any sort of
respect for him of being my father is
just not to know him at all because I
can't understand
how we could do that
and really
so over the past year he gotten really
sick and you know I struggled with we
all did with should we go visit him
um and then ultimately will we go to his
funeral and
we weren't given the opportunity to we
had to find out he was sick through
multiple different parties and
um
so he was remarried his wife had just a
quick burial the obituary wasn't
released till after the funeral
and we weren't even listed anywhere in
it
um
and then since then you know I went back
and looked at the tribute wall on his
obituary and every single person on
their comments about how he was you know
the most dedicated Christian man that
they knew
um
and I'm like he abandoned his entire
family
and I I don't know I have a lot of anger
towards that I thought I had peace about
everything else but now I'm just angry
one of the hardest fantasies in the
world to let go of is a is the parent
walking away from their child
one of the hardest ones in the world and
you can think you've dealt with it and
Buried buried it until they pass away
and then there's that your body realizes
oh this never this never wraps up
there's no there's no
happy ending
yeah in as much as it's frustrating you
you know we've seen enough Hollywood
movies where you know
the kid walks in and Dad's on his
deathbed and he says I'm proud of you
you know what I mean like in yeah that
will never happen
so my question for you is this and it's
a hard one okay
what is this anger getting you
nothing yeah
why are you still at war with him
comprehend how I would do that and you
can't you can't no you can't make
rational sense of an irrational Act
I would tell you any any energy you
spend trying to make sense of it is a
waste of time
it's energy you're taking away from your
kids and dumping into a bottomless pit
you can never wrap your head around it
because it makes no sense
and I know that's maddening
yes
but there's there's this idea of making
peace with my dad walked away from us
forever
and I would let people have their story
about them
because that gives them peace the ones
that he chose to be in relationship that
weren't you
let them have their story
I mean what senses of it is to burn that
to the ground
like you could show up at his old at his
old church and be like hey I'm his
daughter he walked away from and he
never met his grandkids because he
sucked he was the worst guy ever just
wanted y'all to know
my promise is you won't sleep one ounce
Deeper by doing that
yes because I didn't think about that
and of course I stopped myself but yeah
you know how good that would feel it
would feel amazing it would feel so good
the retribution it would feel good for
like five seconds
you know what I mean and on the way home
you'd stop it like a burger joint and
eat yourself into a coma because it
would feel so good
and then you go home and then you'd
realize you went with you
nothing's changed he still walked away
from his little girl
yeah most of the time people get stuck
here it's for two reasons one
it's rage anger feels good
it does
the fantasy of what I'm gonna do or what
I could do feels so good
and the second thing is is there some
sort of lingering dot dot dot that I had
something to do with this
and your body Loops trying to solve what
was it about me that he walked away from
because I can I need to solve that so it
never happens again
and both of those things are unsolvable
Loops they will spin faster and faster
until you become an anxious mess
and then in a strange way you restart
the cycle and your kids want to stay a
few inches away further away from Mom
because she's a lot
is that fair
the cycle starts again
so whenever I someone's facing this that
you've done part of the work okay I
always direct people to write four
different letters
all right
you've written one of them was it the
vomit letter
that you suck and I hate you letter okay
when did you write that
uh when my daughter was born 18 years
ago okay let's update that one okay yeah
so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna write a letter to let them know
what you really think Dear Dad
you suck
you left your daughter you left your
granddaughter you left your sons you
left us all
you created this little fantasy world
that your little fantasy church and you
played
super Christian
while your family wondered why dad left
write that letter
in the second letter which is really
hard to write
is a letter that lets him know what you
miss about him
here's what I missed
and the first letter is usually angry
the second letter is really sad
because you might have some memories of
him when you were really really young
where he was funny or sillier took you
fish in or did something goofy or
whatever he remembers aftershave
whatever the thing is or he would kiss
you and it would it would gristle your
face with his whiskers whatever the
memories you've got locked away in there
here's what I miss
in the third letter
and all these have probably a week or
two weeks between them okay because
they're heavy
the third week is the the third letter
is the one of empowerment
here's what you're gonna miss
your granddaughter is freaking amazing
and because you chose to walk away you
will never know how awesome she is
here's some awesome things she's doing
you're a son-in-law he's the best father
you could ever imagine on and on okay
what we're doing here is we're creating
movement the other way
you're teaching your body by going
through this process that season is over
he's gone
and here's what comes next
then that fourth letter
why did he leave when did he go
he
um like he was a great dad when we were
really little
um my mom and him got divorced when I
was 16. okay my my siblings were already
moved out of the house and graduated
and really we just didn't have much of a
relationship I mean years before he left
why did they get divorced
he was cheating on her with his wife
that he had
so my guess is
um
whether you remember it or not from
about 13 14 and 15 you lived through
hell in that house is that fair
oh absolutely yeah
so your fourth letter is you need to
write Beth
14 15 16 year old Bethel letter and let
her know this was not her fault
because she's still trying to defend you
Fair
yes
she still runs the show a lot
when you got really really pissed when
you were 15 or 16 what did you do did
you did you withdraw did you throw and
kick did you yell and scream what did
you do like just full like angst as a
teenager
I yelled at him I took it all out my
siblings were more reserved and when
they hurt their when he hurt their
feelings they didn't say anything and I
was always the one
to defend them or me or my mom or any
anybody on how he just wasn't there how
often do you yell now as an adult
I have my moments she's still protecting
you
yeah you gotta let her go
when those adult when when we as
grown-ups have those moments of of
childishness
when I ignore when I stamp my literally
I'll stamp my feet and ignore my wife or
my kids or my workmates
that is me being nine all over again
right
that's that little boy coming out being
like oh we'll show them
and it's like no dude you don't get to
drive because you're nine right
similarly
you gotta let that girl go and that's
letter number four
okay
I've also heard folks with some pretty
significant
um success in and you've heard me say
this if you've ever listened to the show
more than a couple of episodes is to go
to the Home Depot or Lowe's or something
and buy a cender block
yes and put duct tape on it and write
your dad's name and write the day the
last day you remember talking to him
in person
or write on that thing you died and
wouldn't even let us come to the funeral
and carry that sucker around your
backyard carry it around your house
until your arms burn look till it gets
so heavy
and then take it as far in the far
corner of your of your backyard or a
park or wherever you find peace
and set that sucker down and rip the
tape off and and in that moment commit
to never picking that brick up again
I'm not carrying my dad's
trauma anymore
I'm not carrying his hatred I'm not
carrying the fact that he walked out on
his little girl and her brothers I'm not
carrying any of this stuff anymore
he doesn't get any more from me
and you're gonna wake up certain days
and you're gonna find yourself carrying
that brick and it's fine you're just
gonna have to remind yourself I'm not
carrying that anymore
you're going to find yourself start to
scream or yell at one of your at
somebody you love and you're gonna stop
yourself mid-yell and be like I'm not
carrying that anymore
I already let Beth Beth little Beth go
she gets to go play
she just go finally be 16 like she
should have been a long time ago
but it's gonna be a practice I'm not
caring anymore I'm not carrying this
anymore I'm not carrying it anymore he
gets no more of me
because he's had enough of you for the
last however many years
and we're done
now it's time to live forward does it
suck that he abandon you God Almighty I
can think of hardly anything worse
is it unbelievable that they hid his
funeral from you didn't even mention you
in the obituary yeah it's wrong it's
wrong at every level and it happened
those four letters are grief
it's a practice of grief it's a practice
of sitting in it and it hurts and it's
probably best if you have somebody that
you can read those letters to maybe your
brothers will join you in this exercise
and you can read your letters out loud
to each other
grief demands a witness you do this
stuff with other people
and if you're really Brave you read that
letter out loud to somebody or to a
couple of people that you write to your
younger self
and we never carry the brick again